السبب الرئيسي الذي يجعل أمريكا تقول إنها لا تزال
في سوريا
هو هناك في الغبار البارد الذي
يخفي بقايا تنظيم الدولة
على مر السنين ، حواجز مثل هذه
السواتر ببطء داعش في مناطق أصغر
وأصغر من الصحراء الأخيرة هناك على
اللوح السوري العراقي حيث  ربما يكون زعيمهم
أبو بكر البغدادي
قد يكون مختبئًا ، لكن في هذه
المرحلة الأخيرة من القتال
، استمرت المشاكل والأعداء الذين
يواجههم الأكراد السوريون هنا وحلفاؤهم الأمريكيون في القتال
الليلة الماضية ،
ظهر عدو جديد آخر بالقرب من هنا
الدبابات و 500 مسلح.  تقدم الموالون للنظام
السوري وقصفوا الكوماندوز الأمريكيين وحلفائهم الأكراد السوريين
ليس بعيدًا إلى الغرب من هنا
قتلت الطائرات الحربية والمروحيات المئات
منهم وهرب البقية ما حدث على الأرض
الليلة الماضية
ولماذا يطارد قائد العمليات الخاصة الأمريكية على ما
أعتقد  أنا مندهش قليلاً
من كان يعرف أن قوات
الدفاع الذاتي في مواقع يمكن الدفاع عنها
ويعرف أنها شرسة
هل يبدأ خصمك بالدوران من
حين لآخر عندما تنظر حولك
وتذهب
حيث يتوقف الأعداء
وأين تبدأ الأخبار السارة
، يمكن أن يكون الأمر معقدًا هنا إذا حاولت
استيعاب كل هذه العوامل ،
فإن الشيء الجيد في أن تكون في
الجيش هو  أننا عادة ما تكون
لدينا مهمة عسكرية ومهمتنا العسكرية هنا هي
هزيمة تنظيم الدولة
عندما بدأ هذا الهجوم ،
اتصل هذا القائد الكردستاني بمراقب عسكري روسي
يهدف إلى الحفاظ على السلام هنا ليسأل عما
كان يحدث
، أخبرني أنه لم تكن هناك تحركات كما
يقول و  ثم كانوا يحدثون
دون إذنهم
بعد ساعة ، اتصل هاتفًا وطلب
وقف إطلاق النار ،
فالغريب أن روسيا قوة عظمى وتعرف عن
أي تحرك من النظام
يتحملون مسؤوليته عن
طرد داعش بالأمس من سوريا وتركت الرقة
بالأسفل فراغًا ولكن  الدمار أيضًا ،
لا أحد يعرف عدد المدفونين
تحت الأنقاض في الأسفل ،
لكننا نحاول المساعدة في إعادة البناء
لتطهير العقول اللانهائية التي اختبأها تنظيم الدولة
حتى في اللعبة.  s أو الثلاجات والدفع
مقابل الشرطة المحلية الجديدة التي تصطف في الشوارع
جيدًا ، فهذا أحد التناقضات
التي تتعامل معها ، فأنت تريد أن
يعود الناس ولكن عليك أيضًا أن تقبل
أنه قد لا يكون من الآمن لهم القيام
بذلك ، فأنت تريد المساعدة
ولكن في نفس الوقت الذي تعلم فيه أنه لا يمكنك
البقاء هنا إلى الأبد ، هل أنت قلق من
الأشخاص الذين ينتهي بهم الأمر بإلقاء اللوم علينا إذا
لم يتم إعادة بناء هذا المكان بسرعة ،
هنا تعلمنا الدروس بطريقة خاطئة
للقيام بذلك وأعتقد
أن  نحن نقوم بعمل جيد للغاية
للتأكد من أن كل ما نقوم به
هنا
هو من خلال مجلس الرقة المدني ،
وهو الهيئة الحاكمة هنا
التي تملي
وتقدم التوجيه لكل ما نقوم
به لمحاولة مساعدة تنظيم الدولة ،
بالتأكيد لم نتوقع أبدًا أن
اجعلنا الكوماندوز
يقومون بجولة في مدرج الإعدام أو
حتى نطلب 20 كباب دجاج
في الشارع هنا رسالة
للعالم الخارجي
أنه آمن بما يكفي وأن
الحياة تندفع إلى هنا لأنه لا
يمكن لأحد الانتظار حتى تصبح الأنقاض نظيفة
إد العقول لتختفي